[Music]
and more meets the eye news more than
damn you dammit dammit and more than
meets the eye news submitted by eat your
veggies thank you for that photos of a
woman kissing strangers around the world
go viral and she doesn't have a partner
I added that last part in I honestly
don't know if she's like in a
relationship or not if she was I don't
know why she would be doing that but
there's all different you know people
are it's interesting but also why would
they go viral is she exactly what did
they caught something viral oh that
could be you know just saying alright so
Christiania she's 23 years old she had
planned a romantic getaway to rekindle a
relationship with her ex-boyfriend but
it didn't go as planned so they broke up
but she ended up going to France anyway
to Paris and so she ended up going with
a friend for support and so she says she
always wanted a really romantic French
getaway and a kissing picture by the
Eiffel Tower so she decided to take
matters into her own hands and go up to
a a handsome stranger and ask him like
hey first of all he she said do you
speak English he was like yes do you
have a girlfriend
no uh are you done taking a picture with
me are you trying to kiss me for a
picture she was like yeah it was like
okay cool I do the same thing before I
see that Christie Christiana she
actually really cute yeah so she's a
student abroad in the UK and this is the
photo I love that person do what they're
dating yeah they do
she's probably posted that as like
revenge you know yeah yeah just hammer
was it like multiple people so then she
ends up tweeting that saying something
along the lines of like oh I hope this
guy I kissed in France is doing good
also this guy I kissed by the Colosseum
I hope he's doing good 200 mm and then
all
so I hope this fireman is doing great
I mean she's super friendly I like
herself fun little album a picture it's
like all the sights of the world with
you kissing strangers exactly because
this one is in Kansas I believe the
location is Virginia sure yeah
downgrading mm-hmm should be a Daytona
Beach Oh or Panama City what's wrong
Panama City everything anything is
Daytona I was just putting the ball on
the tee for you whatever I live in it
and the wind blew in itself yeah and
then it sounded like a fart and that's
what I think of when I think of you okay
cool
yeah thank you lot of people think farts
are funny you think of indigestion what
apartment did you just it's a hard
profession to really make a lot of money
yeah it's magic yeah fart musician music
as I said magician but musician is like
totally different that takes a lot of
skill yeah part musician yeah cuz
musical it's better pitch yeah yeah yeah
so she tweeted those three photos out in
a thread and he kind of went a little
bit viral and so she was just saying
like oh so then there were even other
people posting up their own photos like
this one it was like oh I hope the guy I
had a fling with in Bali once is doing
great and just like all these women just
showing like or like sharing their
spontaneous wilds travel adventures with
strangers and so she was saying
Christiana was saying like you know she
had always been she had always had a lot
of self-confidence issues and so for her
to ask a random cute guy to kiss her
requires confidence and so at that point
she was just like you know what [ __ ]
I'm gonna do this and so she ends up
walking away with like the biggest smile
on her face and with so much confidence
that I became like an adrenaline rush
for her so then once they ended up going
to Rome she did it again
and so and then coming back home she did
it again so now she's just like yeah it
just feels like it's like this pure
innocent moment between two strangers
because there
comments saying like oh my god did you
forget about herpes but she's like at
the end of the day we all kiss strangers
so it's it's just yeah Steve but you
could stop giving me [ __ ] for it
please don't we all do it okay you could
also get hepatitis - did you know that
from kissing someone I didn't yeah so
when I was young and dumb is there more
to the story because no no that's okay
so when I was 15 I have a lot of stories
of me - being dumb I have sores every
being dumb like throughout my entire
life but especially during the era of my
teenage years when I was like addicted
to the Internet and like just like was
really naive about strangers
so downtown Santa Barbara sandbar was a
pretty safe place so I think maybe I was
sheltered a little bit but we're
downtown Santa Barbara meet my friend
Kate she was my best friend in high
school she was kind of an instigator we
would like Panhandle and like back then
you had to use pay phones so you got
like it was easy to like get quarters
from people and then um we'd go up I
like matching rings and stuff like that
anyway when it was around Christmastime
and there was like this guy that thought
that I was cute and since she usually
got a lot of attention it was like oh
she actually thinks I'm cute he was 23 I
was 15 he comes out with mistletoe and
like goes like this and I I'm like all
right and so we kissed instead and then
he stole a bunch of presents for me to
give the people for Christmas what yeah
I don't think they know that that's
where that came from
and then he guessed like had gotten
caught stealing um twice so he like had
like this third like if you know third
offense he'd get locked up you kissed a
vagrant yeah yeah this three-strike rule
yeah but I didn't have that much
experience I was still like a virgin did
you get the Christmas presents from like
he stole them from like like he stole
this like graphics card for a game for a
Playstation I don't know what kind of
game it was for know like from stores I
said that so like I gave them as
presents like he'd be like what would
your brother want like I don't know like
a playstation card he would steal
yeah and then I would have we like give
it I thought that he stole presents for
me I thought that too oh no no he's
still presents for me to give for you
romantic gesture so well spent the whole
day like cuz I was a guy I wish I can
afford presents for my family cuz
there's Christmas time and since we made
out under the mistletoe he's like I
could do it and he I guess like a those
three strikes roll he had one more
strike left before he'd be locked up
forever if he was willing to risk he set
off one of the alarms in the store in
Urban Outfitters and they were like all
the guards came out and they're like
star star come back here and he likes so
smoothly got rid of like whatever he had
in his pocket
they he walked out fresh with them
apologizing I was like oh she's about to
go to jail and like they came out and
we're so sorry we're so so sorry I was
like what happened he's like I got rid
of it my pant leg Wow
do you new know that you knew oh yeah
yeah I just thought he was a badass
yeah Widow so dumb but um but yeah he
was a little bit of [ __ ] Parisian art
thief yeah yeah I mean he was so she was
23 and I was yeah I was 15 were you
standing outside watching him like
you're watching like your friend on
American Ninja Warrior
stage 2 stage 3 no we were going
together and me and my friend would like
be looking at things over here and he
would be over here but yes so she called
me once and then first and then his
phone stopped working like he never
called the game so today I feel like he
did I feel like that would he like got
caught some better his P prepaid phone
card grandma Oh could be baby so I think
the last photo this girl probably have
is her in a back alley I predict that
fire truck that's like I mean I'm I'm no
Bachelorette you know it's probably only
ever kissed a stranger once and that was
in Santa Barbara really yeah it's just
that you know it sets the mood for
kissing strangers yeah cuz you
the Irish dude and he was like I guess
during the summer they get like a ton of
Irish students to go to it with UCSB
yeah I think that Westmont
there's five colleges is one of those
and so I don't know like ended up having
like a shirt that said kiss me I'm Irish
or something I think so you did like I
will no no no my friend like coax me
into doing it I'm just like all right
know that did you kiss him like more
than once no it was literally like the
lamest kazama it was a poser one
stranger story that's it
that was my one stranger kiss story and
that was it yeah I don't know how many I
have but I'm sure up there I only have
that one remembering them is the bigger
channel that's the trick huh and
remembering their names I that's what I
was gonna say about the story I was like
gosh I love how these girls have
locations for all of them so that way
you kind of remember yeah even though if
you don't know their names you like it
was the wrong one you know what I mean
well what I actually became friends on
Facebook with this guy and like Dublin
so I was just like oh I like a pen pal
and open yeah can I suggest something
for your branding can you always have a
glass of red wine in your hand as you
say everything that you say I just think
would help everything I would remind a
glass of red wine now but I am driving
back so have to be responsible no you
don't have to drink you just hold it
hold it was I actually have a picture of
I just have one picture of us in that
Urban Outfitters that he got caught
stealing it's really sweet you know what
I do have that evidence yeah that's so
funny
so I like that you go for the height the
bad boy that knows how to shoplift you
know at the best stores yeah I mean
honestly I probably would have gone for
anyone that gave me attention because
like they always went after my friend
Kate I was like the guy's girl like
everyone want to be friends with me but
not like you and I were the same soul
cuz my sister was that girl like I could
never get rid of it it was like always
there yeah with me yeah I wouldn't have
talked to either of you in high school
they wouldn't have talked to you yeah
you know they were turns out I don't
like guys I tried too hard
[Music]
[Music]